je demande donc à l'assemblée de se
prononcer par un seul vote sur l'article
3 à l'exclusion de toutes sommes à
nantes
à l'exclusion de tout en demandant le
respect de la constitution
ou c'est en fait aujourd'hui de porter
une atteinte très grave à la démocratie
parlementaire et j'en ai honte pour vous
[Musique]
vous comportez comme démarcheur qui
marche sur l'été prix de la démocratie
c'est un moment d'humiliation y compris
pour toutes les personnes qui se sont
mobilisées depuis des mois qui ont fait
un travail extraordinaire pour que ce
texte arrive à l'assemblée ça va laisser
vraiment une image complètement
déplorable de l'organisation de nos de
nos débats je suis très ému et très déçu
cet article 3 bis dans sa rédaction
issue du sénat peut-il connaissance
alors il faudra pas s'étonner demain si
les français écoeuré se détournent de
vous mais surtout de nous tous
[Musique]